24 de septiembre del 2004
ese fue el día que aterricé en madrid
con un billete de ida y unas ganas
tremendas de comerme el mundo
recién graduado de ingeniería industrial
era un empollón motivado con grandes
sueños y cierta ventaja y es que me
había sacado la lotería del ovario
como diría warren buffett el inversor
más exitoso de toda la historia y es que
había nacido una familia que siempre me
había motivado a alcanzar mis sueños y
mi gran sueño
montar una aerolínea
y cuando digo esto normalmente me cruzo
con caras de este estilo que muchas
veces piensan sebastián tú no tienes
cara de mono
bueno pero porque muchas veces los
sueños mueren en el camino uno de los
grandes destructores de sueños lo
descubre en madrid en mi primer trabajo
cuando trabajaba como teleoperador de
equipajes perdidos en el aeropuerto y
este es el síndrome de los lunes
y es un dominicano país pobre donde no
hay paro no hay seguridad social
recopilación y recuerdo que allí tener
trabajo era algo de lo que alegrarse y
mi gran sorpresa fue llegar un lunes al
trabajo y preguntarle a pepe qué tal
pepe cómo estás y su respuesta
del lunes
todos en españa conocemos esta frase
algunos hemos dicho alguna ocasión no
pasa nada es parte del ser humano
el problema es decir la constante mente
y vivir sin pena ni gloria estando cinco
de cada siete días donde no querías
estar siempre deseando que llegue el
viernes
y esto no lo digo yo hay cifras
oficiales que lo avalan la empresa
americana de investigación galo dice que
en europa el 10% de la población
trabajadora hace algo que le encanta
71% no ni fú ni fá
19% lo odia y eso qué significa que si
lo llevamos más o menos algo concreto es
decir este salón podríamos decir que
esta fila disfruta con lo que hacen el
trabajo y los demás en el mejor de los
casos ni fú ni fá y esto es triste
porque a la larga nos lleva a tener
grandes arrepentimientos que en muchas
ocasiones llegan demasiado tarde
por suerte en al menos una solución a
esta situación pero para descubrirla
tenemos que dar un salto a japón porque
al norte de la ciudad de okinawa hay un
pequeño pueblo al que llaman la aldea de
los centenarios porque es el sitio con
el mayor índice de longevidad del mundo
tiene un montón de personas de más de
100 años que se levantan todos los días
a trabajar y además lo hacen porque
quieren porque les apetece el secreto
tener una razón de ser o lo que ellos
llaman gb que es un concepto que le da
la vuelta al mundo un montón de veces en
nuestra búsqueda incansable por alcanzar
la felicidad a españa llegó en un libro
llamado ik y guy también y de manera
práctica los autores lo definen como el
punto de encuentro entre cuatro
variables aquello que te encanta hacer
aquello que se te da muy bien aquello
por lo que pueden pagar te y aquello que
necesita el mundo
yo descubrí michigan y enseñando
habilidades de comunicación pero comencé
a descubrirlo en mi lucha por derribar a
mi propio fantasma sobre todo cuando
toqué fondo para 20 años
como estudiante ingeniero industrial la
asignatura más difícil que hice fue
dibujo técnico para que te hagas una
idea mi hija ni a la que tiene cinco
años dibuja mejor que yo
por lo tanto es el proyecto final de
dibujo técnico tenía muy mala pinta ya
me pudieran ver al final de trimestre
haciendo esto díaz sudando pasándolo
fatal hasta que yo iris mi mamá y me
dijo déjame ayudarte por favor
ella es arquitecta por lo tanto le dije
adelante y me fui a descansar y al cabo
de hora y media ya más tranquilo
relajado decidí que era un momento ir a
ver el progreso salvo que había un
pequeño problema del cual ni ella ni yo
nos habíamos percatado y ese problema es
que mi mamá como arquitecta llevaba años
diseñando por ordenador
cuando llegue la vitalidad y tenía una
expresión en su cara de terror que no
entendía por qué
hasta que lo ve hasta que vi el dibujo
borrones a iones pequeñas roturas el
trabajo de díaz tira una basura
y la frustración y fue tal que no se me
ocurrió nada mejor que el dibujo
y romperlo justo frente a su cara
una nueva y médicas
aquella noche volví me encontré llorando
y me dijo algo que nadie nunca me había
dicho una vez
bastian eres la persona más arrogante
que conozco
yo me había criado con complejos de
inferioridad y lo normal era que cuando
me sentía atacado sacara las uñas
pusieron una cara chulesca defendiendo
mi entorno social se podría más o menos
justificar pero con mi mamá
estaba claro que había algo en mí que
tenía que cambiar y eso me embarco en un
proceso doloroso pero necesario para
luchar contra mis fantasmas un proceso
que me llevó a entender muchas cosas
sobre mí tony robbins el coach más
famoso del mundo dice que los humanos
tenemos seis necesidades fundamentales
certeza variedad conexión relevancia
conocimiento y contribución y que cada
uno de nosotros tiene al menos una de
estas necesidades especialmente marcadas
y la mía la necesidad de relevancia de
sentirme especial de sentir muy
importante y cómo se satisface esa
necesidad con reconocimiento y por esa
razón decidí comenzar a estudiar
habilidades de comunicación por
reconocimiento porque quería trabajo
porque quería amigos porque quería
llegar
en el proceso
descubrió un club de oratoria y ahí vi
la oportunidad fabulosa que lleva
dejando toda la vida y ahora que estarán
atención durante los primeros años en el
club de oratoria lo único que buscaba
era brillar
porque me prestaran atención y es que me
encantaba que me escucharan que me
miraban que miran que me hicieran caso y
me sigue encantando lo que pasa es que
aquella época era algo en cierta medida
enfermizo pero el proceso ocurrió algo
interesante es que a medida que
practicaba se evaluaban iba
desarrollando una habilidad y cuanto más
hablan más me gustaba esto de hablar en
público y al cabo de un tiempo comencé
enseñar de manera informal algunas
personas y luego cobrar un poquito por
ello y unos años más tarde
dejé el trabajo para ser justamente eso
mi propia búsqueda interior
y lucha contra mis propios fantasmas me
hizo descubrir algo que me comenzaba a
gustar que se me estaba comenzando a dar
medianamente bien por lo que van a
pagarme tres de las cuatro patas de
líquido pero faltaba una y la descubrí
más adelante cuando entendí la conexión
que tiene o la relación profunda que
tiene enseñar con otra de las
necesidades básicas de tony robbins y es
la conexión es que un año antes de la
pandemia hice un curso que supuso un
revulsivo importantísimo dentro de mí
sobre todo cuando juan carlos el
profesor me dijo sebastián esto no va de
ti haciendo una especie de referencia a
mi hambre por conseguir atención esto va
de los demás y ciertamente yo llevaba
años hablando en público porque quería
la tensión pero a partir de ese momento
comencé a verlo con otros ojos y me di
cuenta del poder incalculable que tiene
enseñar en términos de conectar
primero para conectar contigo mismo
porque a la hora de enseñar te expones a
la crítica ya comentarios muchas veces
desagradables si ves mi canal en youtube
encontrarás muchos comentarios donde me
dicen que tengo la barba normal afeitada
poco simétrica o que el acento que tengo
es muy extraño ni es del todo español ni
es del todo latinoamericano o
directamente cuando me llaman vende
humos
y al principio duele y como digo al
principio me refiero al primero en el
comentarios duele mucho y te hace
replantearte en muchas cosas pero luego
te das cuenta de que esto te ayuda a
aceptarte a valorar aquello que haces
bien y a comenzar a mejorar allí donde
consideras que hace falta y donde no
pues no pasa nada pre segundo lugar
enseñar es una grandísima herramienta
para conectar con los demás porque
cuando lidera es un proceso en el cual
se supone que puede cambiar la vida a
las personas para que es una la gente
tiene que confiar en ti y eso muchas
veces requiere que muestres tu lado
humano ese que no lo sabe todo pero que
está dispuesto a ayudar allí donde sí
sabe pero cuando tú como formador te
abres las otras personas se dan el
permiso de comenzar a abrirse poco
muestran sus inseguridades sus ganas de
superarlas y es justo ahí cuando ocurre
una especie
de magia
este revulsivo me hizo darme cuenta de
que se iba cerrando el círculo porque
estaba descubriendo algo que me
encantaba hacer que se me daba bien por
lo cual me estaban pagando y en cuarto
lugar que le cambia la vida a la gente
me estaba revelando michigan
atribuyera con función una frase que
dice entrégalo un pescado un hombre y
como era un día enseñar a pescar y como
era toda la vida
esta frase es un cliché del tamaño una
casa pero porque es muy cierta porque
cuando enseñas una avenida a otra
persona
le das una oportunidad de crecer esto le
permite comenzar a cambiar su vida y es
impresionante cuando en una jornada
formativa alguien en el público comienza
a darse cuenta de que puede hacer algo
que no se creía capaz de hacer y en ese
momento se le figura
no sabe si reír o ponerse a llorar esto
yo lo vivo con euforia con entusiasmo
con ternura incluso porque en algunas
ocasiones sobre todo antes del cob y
cuando podíamos abrazar me he puesto a
llorar en sesiones formativas y es que
cuando facilitas cuando ayudas a que
otras personas logren en ese momento se
reafirma tu propio logro y ahí mismo
comienza a satisfacerse otras dos de las
necesidades de las que hablabas un rato
el crecimiento
y la contribución
con todo esto yo te pregunto
qué estás haciendo con tu vida
si al cabo de unos años
miras hacia atrás
me gusta lo que ves
si la respuesta es un sí rotundo te doy
mi más sincera enhorabuena pero si no lo
es quiero proponerte un reto sobre todo
en una época de la historia donde nunca
había sido más importante estar en
constante reinvención
y ahí va el reto y si te lanzas a
enseñar
con esto no tengo que dejes todo de la
noche a la mañana puede que algún día
ocurra puede tampoco te digo que te
dediques al magisterio ni enseñar
habilidades de comunicación lo único que
te digo es que cuando enseñes a otras
personas algo que te encanta ser y se te
da muy bien esto también en una dinámica
donde comienzas a conectarte con tu
propio propósito y si en el proceso te
das cuenta de que puedes ganarte la vida
con ello se abre la puerta a disfrutar
inmensamente de cada día de la semana
incluso de los lunes
y lo bonito del asunto es que para
probar tiene muy poco riesgo porque
primero que nada no hace falta ser
extrovertido pues comenzar 111 a poco no
hace falta que seas gran comunicador a
eso vendrá sobre la marcha no hace falta
que seas el mayor experto en tu área
basta con que se pasó un poquito más que
las otras personas y no hace falta que
te desplaces con un teléfono móvil y una
buena conexión a internet basta en la
gran mayoría de los casos si hacen falta
dos cosas elección y compromiso primero
elección porque todas las respuestas
están dentro de ti en tu propia búsqueda
interior en tu lucha interna y por lo
tanto la decisión tiene que salir de
dentro de ti ahora bien si no lo tienes
muy claro yo te recomiendo que comiences
buscando por todo aquello que cumpla con
dos variables aquello que te encanta ser
y aquello que se te da muy bien puede
ser cocina
contabilidad pilates punto de cross
por trivial que te parezca allí fuera
hay gente que lo necesita pero en
segundo lugar compromiso porque nada
grandioso ocurrir sin dedicación y
esfuerzo y esto yo lo sufrí en carne
propia porque en aquella época la que
estaba en el club de la torá ya con
ganas de hacer algo relacionado con esto
estaba hablando en público cada semana
escribiendo me en cursos leyendo libros
mientras tanto fantasía la con ser
orador motivacional
presentador de la cntv un club del
tiempo
no tenía lo que quería hacer hasta que
un día se me iluminó una bombilla y ya
los voy a enseñar a hablar en público y
en el momento orega fue tan tenso y
lleno de energía y al cabo de un mes
a cabo tres meses
seis meses nada no había hecho nada más
que soñar por miedo por suerte me crucé
con flor ya un tipo con mucha garra que
también enseña habilidades de
comunicación le dije que yo quiero hacer
lo que haces tú pero no sé cómo empezar
y me dijo algo que cambió el rumbo de mi
vida para siempre con fecha y anunciar
si no no lo harás en la vida
y claro como podrían pretender enseñar
en cursos si no había un mi primer pulso
todavía
tarde otros seis meses en atreverme por
miedo
pero cuando ya no pude más anunció una
fecha se la dije a doce amigos les cobre
un poquito pero les cobre por compromiso
porque no podía darme el lujo de
charlene si atrás y tampoco quería que
ellos se echaran hacia atrás y esa
decisión fue el inicio de la actividad
que amo con locura
reconozco que se mira a alguien
con la que me pagan y que ayuda a la
gente esa acción me hizo descubrir
mitigar y tú también puedes descubrir tú
que hay enseñando eso lo que sabe por
esta razón y como seguramente ya
comienzas a pensar en algo yo podrías
enseñar y te recuerdo la mezcla entre
algo que se te da muy bien y eso que te
encanta hacer pues en este momento lo
que toca es comprometerse
comprometerte
y como eligiendo a alguien a quien
puedes comenzar a enseñar esto aunque
sea de manera tentativa por probar y
cómo lo vamos a hacer
te pido que sea gesto muy
y lo digo en serio saca tu móvil
saca tu móvil porque esto cambia vidas
te puede cambiar la tuya y puede cambiar
las de otras personas y ahora piensa en
esa persona a la que puedes ayudar y
cuando lo tengas busca en whatsapp y
diré lo siguiente
tengo algo que enseñarte lo digo en
serio
tengo algo que enseñarte y el resto
caerá por su propio peso si tú quieres y
es que todos tenemos algo que enseñar tú
tienes algo que enseñar y puede que en
este momento no sea algo que te flipé
algo que
especialmente bien o por lo que te
paguen lo que le pueda cambiar la vida a
la gente pero nunca no sabrás si no das
el primer paso porque como decía picasso
la inspiración existe pero tiene que
encontrarte trabajando por eso yo te
digo comienza enseñar
comparte tu sabiduría y puede que esto
no te ayude a alcanzar tus sueños ni que
cambie de la noche a la mañana tu
situación laboral pero si te garantizo
una cosa
en el peor de los casos habrás aprendido
algo nuevo y eso siempre mola pero en el
mejor
habrás descubierto un nuevo sentido a la
vida porque disfrutarás intensamente del
proceso porque conectará de manera muy
profunda con la gente pero además porque
notarás dentro de un cambio muy visible
y ese cambio es el siguiente
cada domingo cuando haya acabado el gran
fin de semana a medida que te vas
metiendo en la cama y vas cerrando los
ojos
escucharás como tu voz interior te dice
mañana
[Aplausos]